No  [Music]  [Music]  be my man you made it you blown up all  over the news are you alone I just want  the money you got the chip all right  start it up why don't you go to the  bathroom wash up we gonna be with you in  a minute  uh-huh come on man your neck it's a mess  initiating combat mode  destiny  all right in and out [ __ ] we're rich  oh we are going to the major leagues  tell people  Jake Oh  get to clinic now it's toilets condition  critical  immediate medical hold on hey hey just  think about all the good [ __ ] we're  gonna have huh oh sorry  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  take the [ __ ] shift X every corporal  cop in this city is gonna be blasting  down these doors after what you and your  psycho friend did we didn't need all  this [ __ ] attention damn it  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  wake the [ __ ] up samurai we have a city  to burn  you